يطلق عليه ba2 وهو نوع فرعي من omicron تم
اكتشافه لأول مرة في منتصف نوفمبر
تم تحديده الآن في 49 دولة على الأقل
بما في ذلك الولايات المتحدة التي
نراقبها عن كثب ويبدو أنه أكثر قابلية
للانتقال ولكن ليس بالضرورة
أكثر شدة مثل الإصدار الأكثر شيوعًا
يحتوي omicron ba2 على عدد كبير من
التغييرات ، حيث يتركز حوالي 20 في
بروتين السنبلة ، وهو جزء الفيروس
الذي تستهدفه اللقاحات ، هل
يتهرب من جهاز المناعة لدينا ، هل يتهرب
من المناعة التي اكتسبناها من
عدوى الأوميكرون أو اللقاحات في
معظم  تشير الدلائل الأولية حتى الآن في تقريرها
الأولي إلى أنه لا يوجد تقرير
من المملكة المتحدة يشير إلى أن اللقاحات الحالية
تحمي أيضًا ضد هذا
البديل الفرعي كما يفعل
متغير omicron الأصلي مع حماية أفضل
ضد الأعراض بمتوسط حوالي 70 با
مائة بعد أسبوعين من  ال
الشيء الوحيد الذي أشعر بالثقة
تجاهه هو أنه سيكون لدينا المزيد من
التباين ، وسيكون لدينا متغيرات مستقبلية ، لذا
فلنبدأ في إعداد خبراء الصحة
لنقول لا م  بعد ما يلقي به المستقبل
علينا ، لدينا الآن الأدوات التي نحتاجها لنكون
جاهزين بما في ذلك اختبار covid19
لإخفاء واسع النطاق وأفضل
حماية ضد التطعيم ضد الفيروس
والمعززات كلما ظهر البديل التالي
سنكون جاهزين لن نضطر إلى إغلاق
في المدارس لن نضطر إلى إغلاق
حياتنا ،
وسنتحكم في طريقنا من أجل دقيقة صحية ، أنا ماندي غايثر